building an infrastructure has more
options than ever but managing
deployments with automated systems and
doing it securely join us as we talk
with 2 Sigma about how they made it
happen on this episode of statue thanks
for joining us Nick tell us a little
more about 2 Sigma and how you manage
your deployments sure thanks for having
us at 2 Sigma we combine data science
and technology as well as financial
expertise and we use that to develop
sophisticated trading models and these
help us uncover value in the world's
markets as you can imagine this requires
the right balance of allowing multiple
stakeholders and researchers to iterate
on research pretty rapidly while still
protecting authorization and controlling
our IP can you show us what that looks
like
sure so this is an exact representation
of our specific environment but it's a
good abstraction that we can use as a
baseline to talk about from so we
started out with just some super admin
identities and then we decided to extend
our on-premise existing source of truth
for identity which in our case is LDAP
to Google identity and we used Google
cloud directory sync to do that then we
use Identity and Access Management
policies to restrict who can access
Google cloud resources this includes
things like Google Cloud Storage buckets
compute instances other services
bigquery a few others how do you lock
down the permissions for these new
resources we create a pretty granule
Identity and Access Management policies
so we can limit who has access to
resources and we also heavily restrict
things that we consider privileged
operations so for us that's anything
that could impact the security posture
of a project like you know I am changes
or changes to the virtual private cloud
structure Google Cloud Storage bucket
permissions or the query data set
permissions we control those pretty
heavily further than that only 2 Sigma
employees have access to our resources
we don't share with any external parties
and we set up specific role based access
controls even within our organization
such as only granting the public cloud
engineering team and reliable
engineering team to access to manage
compute engines
we mandated security keys and 10-minute
session timeouts for our super admins as
you can imagine those a very powerful
accountant we want to protect them
accordingly
we also took a step where we blocked
virtual machine images from being shared
between projects because this was
another control for us to prevent the
exfiltration of my data from potentially
a more secure production environment to
a development environment that's less
lockdown finally we use V PC service
controls and specifically the security
parameters product to protect data in
locations such as Google Cloud storage
and bigquery at the API level these
policies together let us secure access
to our resources and they're pretty easy
for us to edit and iterate on as we
implement additional policies or as we
decide to change our security model so
that secures the users and some of the
data but what about the network all of
our virtual machines are launched in
virtual private cloud environments and
this helps keep them segmented and
segregated at the network level we use
organization policies and firewall rules
to limit access from anything outside of
the V PC to hitting those hosts of
course we had to connect the V pcs to
data sources in our internal data
centers to enable kind of research
workflows and modeling and we use
private inter connect to do that this
communication also enabled accessibility
to our internal Kerberos infrastructure
so we use that to handle system
authentication and authorization at the
operating system layer the same way we
would on frame gives us a unified
authorization model to further lock
things down in all of our V pcs we
remove the write to the internet so that
no external resources can be accessed
from the inside of the V PC by a
computer instance in some very specific
projects we also used identity away
proxy and this helps us authorize a
subset of our researchers to access
specific isolated resources in our DCP
organization in a controlled and secure
manner but still allowing them a little
more flexibility they would floors it
sounds like this was a really iterative
process as you walk down different
portions if you knew now everything you
learned throughout what would you do
differently
ooh we created a lot of tech debt
through duplicating our efforts in our
early exploratory initiatives so you can
imagine we had a bunch of different
projects that we'd set up individually
each of them had their own iam policy is
organization policies and private
connectivity configured you know we've
gone through a lot of different measures
for connectivity so we started out with
public peering then we move to VPN and
finally private interconnect but we
duplicated this infrastructure across
each of those distinct projects and this
led to a lot of complexity and
management overhead and as you can
imagine as you add projects that's just
increases exponentially and we were kind
of tripping over ourselves so in
hindsight I think at an earlier stage if
we decided or architect for shared
services a lot more using things like a
shared vp c using policy inheritance all
things that trickle down from the
organization level i think we would have
been in a better position to build from
y platforms that could be reused by
multiple teams and multiple businesses
much earlier in the process and this
would have saved us a lot of effort and
complexity and we would have been able
to iterate even faster than we do now
thanks so much for sharing your security
journey a pleasure if you'd like to
learn more about setting up IIM policies
including setting them at the
organizational level check out the link
in the description thanks for watching
and make sure to subscribe for more
great Google cloud platform content
we'll see you next time on snapchat
[Music]
you